>>> THIS MORNING REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE FOR GOVERNOR OF W
YORK CONGRESSMAN LEEELDIN IS
SAFE AFTER BEI ATTACKED DURING
A CAMPAIGN EVENT LAST NIGHT.
ZELDIN'S CAMPAIGN SAYS A MAN
CLIMBED ON STAGE AND ATTEMPTED
TO STAB HIM.
CNN'S BRYNN GINGRAS JOINS ME
NOW.
THIS WAS REMARKABLE TO SEE THIS
MAN BE ABLE TO GET ON STAGE THAT
QUICKLY, AND LUCKILY THEY ARE
OKAY.
>> AND I FEEL LIKE WE'VE KIND OF
BEEN SEEING THIS IN ALL
DIFFERENT FORMS.
WE'VE SEEN THIS IN COMEDY, NOW
ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
THE REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE ON
GOVERNOR ON THAT CAMPAIGN STOP,
I WANT YOU TO WATCH WHAT
HAPPENED NEXT.
>> THIS IS OUR LAST STAND FOR
NEW YORK AND THERE'S ONLY --
THERE'S ONLY ONE OPTION --
>> SO IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN A
LITTLE HARD TO SEE FROM THE
DISTANCE THERE, BUT THAT VIDEO
SHOWING REPRESENTATIVE LEE
ZELDIN ON STAGE TALKING IN FRONT
OF THAT CROWD WHEN THIS MAN WHO
WAS IN THE AUDIENCE ACCORDING TO
POLICE WALKS UP AND SWINGS HIS
ARM TOWARDS GLELDEN'S NECK
BEFORE THE CONGRESSMAN GRABS HIS
OTHER ARM AND OTHERS TACKLE THAT
MAN TO THE GROUND, RESTRAINING
HIM UNTIL AUTHORITIES TO GET
THERE.
NOW, ZELDIN SAYS THAT MAN TRIED
TO STAB HIM.
POLICE IDENTIFIED THE ALLEGED
ATTACKER AS 43-YEAR-OLD DAVID
JAKUBONIS.
THEY SAY THEY HAD A WEAPON IN
HIS HAND AND SAID "YOU'RE DONE"
AS HE APPROACHED ZELDIN.
JAKUBONIS IS CHARGED WITH SECOND
DEGREE ATTEMPTED ASSAULT AND HAS
BEEN ARRAIGNED AND GET THIS, HE
IS ALREADY OUT OF JAIL ON HIS
OWN RECOGNIZANCE.
NO ONE WAS HURT AND ZELDIN DID
RETURN TO FINISH HIS CAMPAIGN
SPEECH.
GOVERNOR KATHY HOCHUL SAID THIS
SHE'S RELIEVED TO HEAR THAT
CONGRESSMAN ZELDIN WAS NOT
INJURED AND THAT THAT SUSPECT
WAS TAKE NOON CUSTODY.
I CONDEMN THIS VIOLENT BEHAVIOR
IN THE STRONGEST TERMS POSSIBLE,
IT HAS NO PLACE IN NEW YORK.
OF COURSE, THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT IS UP FOR DISCUSSION ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL, RIGHT, ARE ALL
THESE BAIL REFORM LAWS AND THE
FACT THAT HE IS NO LONGER IN
JAIL AND JUST TERRIFYING
INCIDENT IN TORONTO OF
EVERYBODY.
>> IT'S A TERRIFYING VIDEO.
HIS LITTLE DAUGHTERS AND JUST TO
SEE THAT MAN BE ABLE TO GET UP
ON STAGE THAT QUICKLY IS VERY
QUICKLY.
>> THERE IS NO PLACE FOR IN THIS
OUR SOCIETY.
THANKS, BRYNN.
>> THANK YOU.